Tên công đồ Bộ Tráim không bày sáng đầu tiên của Trung Quốc mang tên tử suyên và số hiệu năm mới mốt đã vừa có bác ngày thử nghiệm chim biển.
Đây là bất kìm tra quan trọng nhằm đến sát tính ủng định và khả năng vận hàng của các hệ thống điện động lực và tý vị liên quan theo chuyên thông viện phương,
tàu đặt yêu cầu chúng chuyên thử nghiệm giận đồ tiên, tàu có sở cho các dạng kiểm tra tiếp theo kiểu khí hoạch.
Bởi lượng giả nước đầy cả trên bốn mươi nghìn tấn,
Tráim không bày sáng đầu đình giả là thể hệ tàu đồ bộ lớn và hiện đánh nhất mà Trung Quốc tử phát triển tàu sở rữ sản mái tòan tru dài và hai đảo tri huy cho phép bạn thành động thần nhiều loại khi tài,
tưu trực thăng mái bây cánh của định cho đến phương tên đồ bộ.
Nếu bánh nhất là hệ thống mái phóng và hám định tự, công nghệ thường chỉ thấy trên tàu dân bài.
Sử dụiện của Tráim không bày sáng,
cho thấy Trung Quốc đang tiếp tục mở giống năng lực ở chiến sà bờ,
đồng thời tương bương hỏng thiện các niệnh tảng hỗ trợ cho chính lực hại quân xa hàng.